now this talk the emphasis is on simple
so i can promise you there's going to be
no machine learning because interesting
as it is it's not very simple
and hopefully this will be
something anyone can understand i am
going to go into details and do some
demos but the idea is that it's
it's a recommendation engine that we can
all we can all understand
so
you've probably noticed
the recommendation engines are
everywhere these days think about
your day today
have you done something
in response to a recommendation
algorithm
maybe you spoke to someone on a social
network because
an algorithm showed you their post maybe
you bought something because you were
recommended it online maybe you got into
an argument
because
an algorithm showed you something you
disagree with maybe you listen to a song
so my interest in music means that
i use different music services and i
found
the
the recommendations sometimes very good
sometimes not sometimes predictable i
thought
given recommenders are taking over the
worlds maybe i can make a recommendation
algorithm and then at least i'll know
what's going on with it
but i'm an operating systems developer
so i have to start from scratch i
thought
what goes in to a recommendation
algorithm well data goes in
then there's a process
and then some more data which is
hopefully hopefully more interesting
will come out of the other side
uh in the case of a music recommender
then on the right hand side we will get
a list of songs
on the input side it's more complicated
you might
take a music collection
well a music collection is really a list
of songs but where the order isn't
important
you might take social data like other
people's playlists well those are also
lists of songs
maybe you'll take the history of what
someone listened to
in the past which is also a list of
songs ordered by time
and maybe you look at analysis of the
pieces of music that might say how fast
it is how dark it is whether it's metal
or scar or
gospel
which we could really keep that data in
a playlist as well if we can store
that data alongside the songs
so
we can already simplify this
back down to a playlist goes in some
kind of processing happens and a
playlist comes out
as long as we can do arbitrary playlists
then we can have this simple model
um that's nice because this to me looks
like a shell pipeline as an operating
systems developer i spend a lot of time
writing shell pipelines
um as data scientists we more likely to
use something like ipython jupiter
and the same tools work for modeling
pipelines whatever you want to use
so how do we represent
a playlist
i've been using the simple json format
where each line is a json object
and a set of attributes describe the
songs
and i've created some python codes
wrapped up in a command line tool
called caliop or kaliope depending how
you want to pronounce it
and that allows me to create some
pipelines so here's a very simple
i wouldn't call it a recommender yet but
a playlist generation pipeline so it
asks the tracker search engine
on my my computer
to show all of the songs i have
and then it shuffles the list chooses
five
and then uses another command line tool
to select just the title and the creator
and there we go we created a playlist
already
i want to talk a bit more about the
format
firstly the fact that it's a list of
json objects is deliberate that makes it
more usable in a traditional command
line because
you can start the tool on the left
and it prints an object and then another
one and then another one and the next
tool in the pipeline can read these as
you go so you don't have to generate a
huge list of a million songs wait for
that then shuffle it
in the case of shuffle you do have to
wait but in the case of other processing
you can do it a line at a time
and it's a kind of lazy evaluation
apart from that the playlist format is
not special it's an adaptation of spiff
xspf which is
uh already existing since 2006 i think
uh it's a standard pretty common
playlist format it's based on xml which
i have not used
because it's no longer 2006
but pretty much everything else is the
same
uh one really cool thing about spiff is
it's described as portable
in the case of a playlist
being portable
means that it's not tied to a specific
streaming or storage medium if you have
a list of files on your computer that's
not portable you can't play it on a
different computer
so the way spiff works
is you record details about the song
like title artist
and then later you resolve it to some
actual content
so
i want to dive in already with some
demos to show
how this works and how easy it is to
play with it these are all live demos
things can break uh please bear with me
but let's
let's see what happens so i've got a
playlist here
but i can't play the playlist
because it's just a
adjacent object
so
what if
we resolve the playlist against the
spotify web api
this is using an api api key that i've
got saved locally
and
out the pipeline comes another json
object i'm going to run this into
the jq tool so it comes out in color
there we go much better
so now you can see we've got the title
the creator
and we've got a load of metadata from
spotify including
somewhere
well we should have a location field
but now we
don't this changed recently but we have
enough information that we can generate
a spotify url
what about a different service we could
resolve against
music brains
same input
and this
you would expect that to work ah
the command is different so
i'm gonna annotate it
with some information from music brains
again it's a live demo
the results are cached but obviously my
cache is empty so if i run this a second
time it will be fast
okay and now we have some information
from musicbrainz
um
i could also resolve this against files
on my local computer
there's another command which interfaces
with the beats
music library which is a cool python
tool to organize your music library so i
can ask beats
for a list of all the tracks
uh it's quite slow because there's some
improvements needed in beats
in fact that's too slow let me show you
albums instead
okay
hopefully by now you're seeing that
all this tool callup does really
is it's a toolkit for reading data
from disparate places
and writing it out in a standardized
format which is the first thing we need
to do some kind of interesting
recommendations
most of these tools are simple they are
a few hundred lines of python or a
thousand lines maybe and the more
complicated ones
and i intend for them to stay that way
now
this is a nice way to generate playlists
but
i also want to show you
[Music]
that you can export to a number of
different playlist formats so now we
generated our
resolve spotify playlist i can now
export it in xspf format for example
and i can now import that into a music
player application or put it on my ipod
or anything
so back to the slides
let's talk a little bit about spotify
spotify is probably
the number one
in music recommendations
as of today
by their own numbers they have
thousands of engineers working on the
product
they have
thousands of data pipelines running
constantly
um they have 50 million tracks
um
a quarter of which nobody's ever
listened to
and they are capturing half a trillion
events
every day
so that's a lot of events per user i
think there's about 250 million users
right so i think how many events they're
capturing per user they know a lot
about you more than just
a list of songs that you listen to
what can they do with that data quite a
lot
can we compete with spotify
in the open source world that would be
difficult right because we don't have 16
000 engineers at our disposal
but we also don't need to
something anything is better than
nothing right
so
an open source music recommender even a
very basic one
is already kind of fun it's already
helping us learn about music
recommendations and it's already
helping us not depend on spotify
so
if we're going to recommend
songs we need more than just randomness
we need some data
i'm going to talk about some open places
and some not open places that we can get
data from
firstly musicbrainz
which is a website
it's kind of a catalogue
so you can go on musicbrainz and you can
look up any music release any song and
it will tell you way more information
than you ever
wanted it can tell you
when and where something was recorded
what record label it was on who else has
released music on that record label who
produced the albums
when they were born
huge amounts of data
the data result open data it's released
under an open license the website itself
is open
it's maintained by volunteers so it's a
really cool
data source to use
and obviously cali up interfaces with
that
and lets you make use of the music
brains data so we have lots of ideas of
fun things like recommending artists on
the same record label or from the same
place
listen brains is from the same team as
music brains and it's a way to record
your listening history so you can hook
it up to your
music player you can install a browser
add-on called what's it called
web scroller
and that'll record things you play in
your web browser to listen brains
you can look at other people's listens
and it gives you some kind of analysis
about what you've been listening to
so start using that it's really fun
and in future it's going to mean you can
get better music recommendations
because spotify if you use spotify they
record your listening habits as well but
they won't give it back to you
even if you go through the long process
of request all my data
which they have to do
legally they still only give you one
year of your listening history
they won't give you everything unless
you specifically ask for it so
if you're not start using listen brains
it's more
this website in the bottom left is last
fm which is actually an older website
for recording
what you listen to it's not an open
website it's owned by um
cbs interactive i think
but kaliop can also interface with that
i
have been
recording the music i listened to for
years
and
i used to do this with last fm
lustfm has an api as well with a lot of
tags created by users so there's an
interesting data source
you can look up an artist and see what
millions of users have labeled it as and
we can use that for recommendations
finally spotify actually has a really
powerful adi and you can access
spotify's own data so my last image in
the bottom right
has spotify's an example of the spotify
analysis you can get for a song like how
danceable it is
uh what key it's in whether it's got
lots of speech whether it sounds
acoustic
now
i don't think you can query 5 million
songs using this api but you can
probably query 20 or 30 songs for free
with no problem
so there's a lot of interesting data we
can use
i'm going to show a couple more demos
of things that you can do with the
listening history now i said to use
listen brains
i'm a bad example here because i'm still
using last fn so i'm going to be showing
the last fm history command
um kaliop doesn't yet support listen
brains but it will uh be a fun thing to
contribute if you want to join in the
project
let me
show you
what the last fm history command can do
so
if i give it my username and i say
that's not the command
that's the command so i say give me a
list of the scrobbles which is the
last five songs i listened to and there
we go there's the last five songs i
listened to
in the form of a playlist
um
let's mine this data a bit more
so i can ask what artists i've listened
to i wonder if i've got this one
recorded in my
backlog yes so
i'm asking it for all the artists i've
listened to in the last six months
so i'm saying
there's an sql database in the back end
here which i'm not going to show you but
in the background this is scraping the
last fm data putting it in an sql
database so that we can query it locally
and now i'm saying query everything i've
listened to in the last six months
and
only returned things which i listen to
10 times or more
and then i'm gonna select just the
creator field because that's the only
one we care about
so here's a list
of all the artists i discovered in the
last six months and i must have liked
them because i listened to them 10 times
or more
say what you want about my taste of
music is quite obscure
but now we could perhaps make a playlist
of these artists
uh i'm not gonna show you how
what am i gonna show you
ah here's another interesting thing we
can do kind of the inverse
i can say show me all the tracks
which
i didn't play in the last one year
this is going to be a lot of tracks i
think let's see how many it is i'm going
to count how many it is using the word
count
so 34 000 tracks
which i haven't listened to in the last
year but i listened to before that
um how can we make a playlist let's
randomly pick five songs
okay so there's an interesting playlist
five songs that i haven't listened to in
the last five years
is there anything else we can do
select
okay
the last thing i want to talk about
before we break a bit for questions
is the select command so shuffle is fine
but there's nothing really too smart
going on there we're taking the data
randomly shuffling it
and spitting it out that's already a lot
better than nothing
but let's do something a bit more
advanced so the select command uses a
simple type of algorithm called a local
search
and so i can feed in this data
randomize it
and then i can say
give me a playlist
with a duration of
60 minutes
now because there's a pipeline i need to
put a dash
to tell each command to read from the
previous pipeline let's see what this
comes up with actually 60 minutes is
quite long
let's have a 30 minute playlist so that
hopefully it fits on the screen
hopefully this doesn't take
too long
in fact
uh this isn't going to work because we
haven't annotated it with the duration
information
so
that's possible
but it's outside the scope of this talk
what i would do next would be to
resolve the files somehow either against
my local music collection or against
music brains to find out how long they
are
and then i would have the duration field
and then
i could
actually
select them based on the duration but
because time is short i'm going to move
on to the last slide
which is a paper i read
and this is where i got the idea for the
select command
so it's from 2008
and
you can read this
online for free the link is in the
slides which are in my talk
and
it uses what's called a local search
algorithm to recommend playlists local
search is quite a simple algorithm in
the sense that
it's what a person might do if you had
to choose from a pool of a thousand
songs
and you had some constraints
then you start by picking one and you
pick another
and eventually you've got too many and
you throw some of them away and then you
pick some more until your playlist fits
the constraints
there's more to it than that but that's
that's the fundamental this paper is a
really interesting read they demonstrate
recommending music generating playlists
by defining a series of constraints so
here's an example from the paper
of one of the tests they did in their
research
and there's a list of different
constraints now the right hand side is
this is an academic paper so it's quite
mathematical but on the left hand side
in the description column
you can see
the first constraint is that all the
songs should be different
the second constraint is that they
should be released between 1980 2001.
the third constraint is that 20 should
be stevie wonder always a good choice
and so on
and a local search algorithm can take a
collection of songs and it can find the
best
not the best but a
result which satisfies those constraints
and the the select command
is an implementation of that now it's
not a complete implementation although
this is very simple
but
this is how i really think we're going
to get some engaging and some useful
open-source music recommendations
so
just to summarize
recommendation engines
are a thing they're here to stay kids
now are growing up watching youtube and
using recommenders every day
and they're going to become more and
more a fact of life
the callio project
aims to make simple fun music
recommendations it's a project you can
hack on and use right now you can pip
install it
and run it from the command line
it's full of bugs so please open issues
and merge requests with whatever you
find it's something i work on in my
spare time and i don't have time to
polish it
um and one final point i think the
design of calliope is much more
important than the code i think the
model of simple self-contained tools
which communicate with a well-defined
format can work for any type of
recommendations not just music
it can work for any programming language
not just python
and with that i'm interested to see if
there are any questions
let me
i'll leave the screen sharing but that's
the end of the talk